[Music]
hello my fellow anime fans and welcome
to Vinnie tube and today i'll be the one
narrating this video you can check out
my channel the entertainment reagent
i'll leave the link in the description
box below we'll be taking a look at the
top 10 ice users in anime so stick
around because it's about to get cooler
number ten we have Steven star phase
from gikai sensing this guy gives new
meaning to the phrase cooler the
cucumber always suave and his business
suit in snarky comments mr. star phrase
is equally cool ice abilities with his
blood no less as a man who reportedly
speaks nine languages boy that's a lot
of languages his abilities are mostly in
Spanish and they're also spoken as such
by him whenever he uses them very rarely
do you hear the words is school dead
cero absolute doll spoken in anime but
hey that's what Steven a star face does
best amigo with a vast array of ice
blood weaponry disposal including a
lance and blades he definitely makes the
start of our list number nine its Giotto
from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure bento AO
whilst not the fans favorite entry in
the much-beloved manum a gaucho
newsstand white album maker lists due to
how much of an oddball he is and how
different his mannerisms are to his
stands I see abilities gas shows temper
is unbelievably short and it gets angry
at the silliest things his stand however
has the ability to induce chilling
temperatures in mere seconds if your
refrigerator ever breaks down I guess
you can count understand to bail your
food out with one touch it was able to
freeze gasoline to a temperature of
negative 100 degrees Celsius almost
instantaneously just like star phase
he's able to make weapons from the ice
but his crown jewel
as it stands gently weeps ability using
it as a last-ditch effort his
temperature drops to a staggering
negative 210 degrees Celsius freezing
the air around him
loaded up to number eight we have great
from fairytale gray Fullbuster his body
build and tone scream cry oh man sir
don't they the cool blue eyes the strong
as icebergs abs and a serious attitude
when the going gets tough gray like most
ice users on this list can use its ice
make magic to create ice shaped objects
including weapons
he's so adept at ice magic he was able
to freeze juvie his boiling water well
that's not all when his father's time
King to pass he inherited his icy devil
Slayer magic and was able to do the most
incredible things with it if you've ever
wanted to watch an ice user go all out
with ice everywhere grateful Buster's
definitely your go-to
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and number seven it's November 11 from
darker than black ever thought how a
blood vendor from Avatar be like you've
Unleashed into the world of anime
I think November 11th fits the bill
perfectly as a contractor the man known
as Jack Simon has cryo kinetic abilities
or more formally liquid induced cryo
Kinesis in layman's terms he's able to
freeze any liquid with sheer power of
will this alludes to my previous blood
bending point as he's able to freeze
blood in the human body without even
having to make contact with it at all
he's cold distant and motionless from
fighting but sometimes cracks jokes when
he can he's also got the standard ice
shield and projectiles kit as well
though did I mention he egged cigarettes
even though he smokes them themself
[Music]
we're now up to number six with Jude our
from Maggie as one of the four moggy of
the current era due to our specializes
in ice magic even though he's got access
to other forms of magic his McCoy is
strongest when employing nice as
brashness child as says he is Judah is a
capable fighter who's able to freeze the
water random and then utilize it as Thal
galas a loose or a rain of ice spears
that frees an area once they touch it
last but most certainly not least he can
combine his magic with wind to form fel
algea or tornadoes that actively zero in
on his opponents every time this guy's
on screen it's a spectacle for sure
[Music]
and number five we have Haku from Naruto
disliking a state of being as a tool to
kill Haku tried not to mortally wound
his opponents as much as possible in
terms of his powers he combines
incredible speed with his elite training
from Zabuza along with his awesome
abilities to effectively use his chakra
iced release his demon mirroring ice
crystals are a force to be reckoned with
as it would seem as he was traveling
between all the sheets of ice he could
also use his thousand flying water
needle as a death technique to transform
the water around him into needles it can
use terrain attacks on his foes
[Music]
porty and number four it says death from
a comedic hill the strong survive and
the weak die is most certainly the motto
of a nice user don't you think it's what
is caused as death to lose all manner of
empathy towards anyone in her life
despite this she has unparalleled
charisma and equally unparalleled
mastery over ice after choosing your
tegu she can build ice bridges create
little ice daggers protect herself with
icy shields and even in case her enemies
in ice she even had a plan to create a
whole cavalry of Isis substituted troops
at some point her powers were so strong
she could have grows in time itself talk
about cold-hearted again always tonight
it's Todoroki from Boko new hero
academia if you've ever seen to face
from Batman I have bad analogy for his
character I know but bear with me
he's got the half-and-half thing going
on in style sporting a head of white and
red hair as well as turquoise and grey
eyes he had an unconventionally rough
childhood constantly hating the left
side of his face because it reminded him
of his father he wouldn't you his
abilities on that side until he was
pushed to his limits and unleashed a
full power of the Han rayhan on his
right side has his ice powers where he
can use them to freeze temperature of
objects as well as create ice weapons
including a giant ice wall as well as
waves of ice he's so used to naturally
use his right side that has become
almost second nature making his fighting
style all too predictable nevertheless
he's still able to use his abilities to
their full potential sometimes defeating
enemies with the simplest and least
number of movements
she was feeling and Roger much porn the
clarinet is you honor
[Music]
up next its hitsugaya from Bleach and
number two the youngest captain of the
10th division that's I see here serious
badass wields the power of the hero new
motto out of all the ice elements it is
considered the strongest in both shikai
and bankai forms his control over them
may be strong but they're strong enough
to backfire on him as well when used in
shock I the Crescent blade appears
attached to a chain which can be used to
ensnare foes as a means of attack and
when imbued with enough spirit power
couldn't turn the tip of the blade into
an ice dragon when histor guy uses
bankai he's encased in ice and forms
wings as well as a tail all these new
appendages are movable and can help
hitsugaya out of tough spots his bankai
special abilities include regeneration
if there's water around him at any point
in time and creating an ice clone as a
diversion if he ever finds himself in a
sticky situation
[Applause]
Oh finally at number one it's out key G
from one piece it was tough picking the
number one for this list but who better
to take the throne with someone who can
actually be ice he has the power to
freeze several miles of the ocean his
fighting style is to primarily
incapacitate his opponents using his
powers by freezing him in place
threatening to shatter their bodies they
try anything against him not only that
but I'll key D is the ability to break
himself up into the ice and that
includes saltwater as well meaning we
could escape him to see if he wants to
howl kg can also use the power of his
devil fruit to his advantage as shown
when he throws the water underneath him
when he was using the bicycle to cross
the sea one time
[Music]
and there you have it we'd love to hear
your thoughts on this topic if you'd
like don't hesitate to add in your
favorite ice users in the comment
section below don't forget to leave a
like if you enjoyed the video and
subscribe if you haven't already and
yeah this is just a general reminder
this is the entertainment region so
please check out my channel link in the
description below we'll see you next
time
on Vinnie to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]